So, I'm going to take up in December the 5th, 1916, the good that the soul who lives
in the divine will does.
I was doing my meditation according to my usual way, that's what she does every day,
so I was pouring all of myself into the will of my sweet Jesus.
That's like saying to Jesus, "I've fused all of me in all of you."
So, I often say that to him, "I've fused all of me in all of you all the time."
I was pouring all of myself in the will of my sweet Jesus.
In the meantime, I saw an engine before my mind, which contained innumerable fountains,
which poured waves of water, light and fire.
And rising up to heaven, these would pour on all souls.
There was no soul that was not inundated with these waves.
The only difference was that for some, they entered inside while for others, they stayed
outside.
In other words, some people are disposed to receive and others are not yet disposed.
And Jesus told me, "My daughter, I am the engine, so you should have a capital E on
that engine."
And my love keeps the engine in motion and it pours over everyone.
Now, notice that he is completely universalist.
God loves everybody, the same as everybody else.
But for those who want to receive these ways, if they are empty and they love me, they enter
into them while the others who are just touched in order to be disposed to receive such a
good.
Now, notice that we are an empty space in which God will work.
Okay, so I want to give you Ephesians 2, 10 for that we are God's work of art created
in Christ Jesus.
We are a space.
That's why we have to go into our nothingness, not because the Lord wants to humiliate us
or even that we want to humiliate ourselves, is that we want to become a place where the
Lord can create.
And he creates out of nothing, you see.
So as for souls who do my will and live in it, those are living in the divine will, then
they are inside the engine itself.
Now the first two groups are outside of the engine and some of them are open to let the
graces pour into them and some of them only need to be disposed, they are not yet ready.
But if you live in the divine will, you are already inside of the engine itself.
And since they live from me, they can dispose the waves that gush out for the good of others
and are now light that illuminates fire that ignites and water that purifies.
So you become the light, you become the water, you become the fire.
So you become the light that's Matthew 5 and I think it's verse 14 or 17, I think I put
down 17, you are the light of the world, do you remember?
Yes.
Okay.
Fire that ignites, in other words, if there's fire in your belly, it will give life to others.
Water that purifies, water is a symbol of the living waters of grace.
How beautiful it is to see these souls who live in my of my will or in my will coming
out from within my engine like as many other little engines diffusing themselves for the
good of all.
Now notice for those of us living in the divine will that he is our everything, we're coming
out of him and that's why we can do good for others.
And then they return into the engine and disappear from the midst of creatures and they live
from me and me alone.
Now notice that life in the divine will is a life of union with God, we're living for
him alone and we come out of him to do good for others, okay?
So I want to give you Galatians 2.20, I no longer live, it is Christ who lives in me.
So December the 9th, 1916, Jesus wants to find himself and what he did in the soul,
so to find himself and his works in the soul.
With this intention, the soul must do the hours of the passion and every other action.
Okay, so this is a very important message.
Louisa said, "I was afflicted because of the privations of my sweet Jesus and if he comes
while I breathe a little bit of life, I am left more afflicted in seeing him, more afflicted
than I am."
He doesn't want to hear about placating himself because the people are forcing him and they
snatch more scourges from him.
And while he scourges, he also cries over the lot of man, why does he scourge because
he's got to put a correction into the system?
Why does he cry over the lot of man?
That is not his will and he doesn't want this awful relationship with the human race.
He has done everything to create us and to save us and to give us life.
And so Louisa said, "He hides deep within my heart.
He hides deep within the heart of anyone who lives in the divine will."
And he goes not to see what man suffers.
It seems that one can no longer live in these sad times, yet it seems that this is only
the beginning.
You see, it's still in the middle of World War I, 1914 to 18, and it's only the beginning.
The Lord has already intimated there will be another World War.
He didn't use those words naturally enough.
And as far as we know, there will be a third World War as well.
So it's only the beginning.
And when you go to the Book of Revelation, there are three major waves of chastisement.
And it seems to me that it's the Three World Wars.
Okay.
Then as I was worried about my heart and sad lot of having to be so very often without
Jesus, he came and throwing his arm around my neck, he said, "My daughter, do not increase
my pains by worrying.
Now don't forget that Jesus is speaking to her with the two of them literally inseparable."
Okay.
So if two things are inseparable, what happens to one happens to the other.
So her worrying is worrying him.
Her pains are increasing his pains.
"There are already too many," he said, "I don't expect this from you.
On the contrary, I want you to make my pains, my prayers, and all of myself your own."
You see, we pray that way in the hours of the Passion.
In such a way that I may find in you another me, so we associate with him, we follow, we
repeat.
Remember those words that Tony gave us, "associate, follow, and repeat."
In these times, I want great satisfactions, in other words, during a World War.
And only one who makes me their own can give them to me.
It's only when we really fuse in the divine will and take Jesus's reparations and Jesus's
sufferings that we have something to give to God with nothing of our own.
That which the Father found in me, which is glory, delight, love, satisfactions, whole
and perfect, and for the good of all, I want to find in these souls.
So for that, I want to give you John 14, 12.
My disciples will do the same works as I do when I go to the Father.
And John 15, 7, he wants his disciples to do the same.
I want to find in these souls, like as many other Jesus' that match me, we have to be
like him in everything.
These intentions you must repeat in each hour of the Passion, hence you have that prayer
at the very beginning to fuse in the divine will and join in all that Jesus is doing.
What you have to do is in each action as well, in everything.
So if I don't find my satisfaction, it's all over for the world.
Now, this is 1916.
I can't even imagine how he feels now.
I can't even imagine.
We're in an infinitely worse situation.
In other words, he needs as many people as possible in the divine will doing these reparations
through the Passion for him, but fused with him in the divine will.
The scourges will pour down in torrents, and then he said, "My daughter, my daughter,
he disappeared."
So there's the necessity for all of us to actually join forces and become an army of
people in the divine will fused with Jesus in his humanity, divinity, and will, taking
all of his satisfactions and all of his reparations and making them our own and offering them for
the poor world that we're living in.
And it's the sheer numbers of us that are required to do that because we're not in the
same position as Louisa.
So December 14, 1916, Jesus slept and worked in order to give rest to souls in God.
Louisa was offering her sleep to Jesus and saying to him, "I take your sleep.
This is a very good little prayer before you go to sleep.
And I make it my own, and by sleeping with your sleep, I want to give you the contentment
as if another Jesus was sleeping, it's short and sweet and to the point."
Without letting me finish, he said, "Yes, my daughter, sleep with my sleep.
For that, I want to give you Sam 127, too."
So that in looking at you, I may reflect myself in you, in other words, Jesus may see himself
in us.
And as I gaze at myself, I may find all of myself in you because you are sleeping with
my sleep.
In other words, your sleep isn't just the body resting.
It isn't just the mind or the emotions resting.
Your very spirit is resting in God and therefore it's an act of spiritual reality that's there.
And so as you gaze at yourself in me, we may be in accord in everything.
I want to tell you why my humanity subjected itself to the weakness of sleep.
Now notice, because he was divine, he calls it weakness.
Because we're human and weak and all the rest of it we call it an absolute necessity.
It's a completely different matter altogether.
We would be ill if we deprived ourselves of sleep, whereas for him, it was completely
different.
Isn't it amazing?
He said, "My daughter, the creature was made by me.
And as my own, I wanted to keep her on my lap in my arms in continuous rest."
Now that is Sam 131, verses 1 to 3.
My soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap.
I've given you that many times, haven't I?
I also want to give you Sam 95, verse 11.
Sam 37, verse 7.
And the call of Jesus in Matthew 11, 28 to 30, "Come to me, I will give you a rest."
Okay.
Your rest is your mind, your heart, your soul, your whole being in union with God.
That's Matthew 11, 28 to 30.
My soul was to rest in my will, now sorry, the soul was to rest in my will and sanctity,
to rest in my love, to rest in my beauty, my power, my wisdom, all these acts which constitute
true rest.
So what he's calling rest is not sleep.
It is that you have found your origin and you have found your destiny.
You have found everything when you touch the divine will and the sanctity of the divine
will when you touch divine love, beauty, power, and with that actually requires contemplation.
And we'll talk to you about that in our next gathering.
All these acts which constitute true rest, but what sorrow.
The soul escapes from my lap and trying to detach herself from my arms in which I hold
her tight.
She goes in search of vigil.
Now I thought the word vigil there was used wrongly.
We use the word vigil to mean I am keeping vigil sort of all night before the blessed
sacrament.
You're staying awake, that's not the way it's being used here, it means distractions,
that you're paying attention to something that is not God and is not the divine will.
So I want to give you Mark 631.
People just don't want to know what the Lord is saying.
So to let you know that I'm not misreading it, he then said vigil our passions, sin,
attachments, pleasures, vigil are the fears, the anxieties, the agitation.
In other words, the things that distract you from the will of God and the presence of God
and bring you down and pull you down to a much lower level.
So as much as I long for her and call her to rest in me, I'm not listened to.
This is a great offence and a front to my love, which the creature takes into no consideration.
And she gives not a thought to repair for it.
In other words, the creature doesn't have a clue what she or he is doing to themselves
by allowing this to happen to them.
This is why I wanted to sleep, in other words to make reparation for our sleep.
Every single thing that he did in his life was to redo all the things that we do wrong
in our lives.
That's why we have a divine version of us in heaven which we can claim.
So this is why I wanted to sleep, he said, to give satisfaction to the Father for the
rest which souls do not take in him by repaying him for everybody.
And while sleeping, I penetrated true rest for all.
Making myself, look at this, the vigil, I don't know why, she suddenly got, the translator
suddenly got this word and is using it all over the place, making myself the sentry of
each heart.
In other words, the one who takes care of you, in order to free them of the problems
of sin.
Here's the word vigil used wrong several times, okay.
So the Lord makes himself the sentry or the guard of our hearts to protect us from the
distractions and the disaster of sin.
And I so much love this rest of the soul in me that I do, I not only wanted sleep but
I wanted to walk in order to give rest to her feet, work to give rest to her hands,
palpitate and love to give rest to her heart.
In some, I wanted to do everything so that the soul might do everything in me and would
take rest.
Now you see the rest there is that your whole being is resonating right in the centre of
God's will and therefore everything that is happening in that rest is actually totally
life giving.
So it's not rest as in you know, many people want to sleep to sort of forget stuff, to
just sort of put off something out of tomorrow, you know, tomorrow is another day, I'm going
to sleep to your mind, tomorrow is another day.
So that's not that kind of thing at all, it's not sleep as in escape from anything.
So this rest is something that you can do fully awake, fully alert in prayer and it
is the most wonderful thing and if you have never truly experienced it, instead of trying
to put your head around it and work it out intellectually, the simplest solution is to
find a place where you can be alone and be quiet and ask the Lord to let you experience
this rest because when you experience it you understand it whereas you could do all the
talking from now until next year about it and if you have not actually experienced it
you don't know that this is the solution to health of body, mind and spirit.
It's also finding our centre, it's the most wonderful thing and medical science today
has recognized that meditation is what they call anything to do with prayer, whether it
is prayer or not, all kinds of stuff they call meditation but they recognize that if
a person becomes very quiet interiorly that it is very health giving for mind and body,
very health giving.
So the Lord wants us to take rest but our rest is the child in its mother's arms, it's
us in the arms of the Lord so that I might do everything for her.
You see the image there of the child again that when the child is in the mother's arms
the mother is doing everything, the mother is thinking about everything that the child
needs and all the rest of it and the mother is being the protector and the guard and protects
the child from all trouble, well the Lord wants us interiorly in that position so that
he can mother us, now let me use that word, is that okay?
So that I might do everything for her provided that I could keep her safe within me.
Now it's when we finally click in to that living in the divine will 24/7/365 when we
finally click in to that all of this comes your normal reality until then you will experience
it every now and then.
So December 22nd 1916 everything that the soul does in the will of God Jesus does together
with her this is terribly important.
So if I fuse myself in the divine will and then do any prayer he's praying with me and
it is very good for me to remember that isn't it?
Okay so there's a very beautiful prayer here in the first paragraph.
Having received communion I was uniting all of myself, you see I unite all of me with
all of you and pouring all of myself into his will and I said to him I'm unable to do
anything or say anything therefore I feel the great need to do what you do and to repeat
your own words.
In your will I find present and as though in act the acts that you did in receiving yourself
in the circle now everything Jesus did because he was divine and human all those actions
are all alive we can plug into them anytime we like to receive the life that they give.
So she wanted to enter into the acts that Jesus did in receiving himself in the Holy
Eucharist.
I want to make them my own she said and I want to repeat them for you it's a very important
thing to do after receiving Holy Communion.
So I tried to penetrate into everything which Jesus had done in receiving himself in the
circle and while I was doing this he told me my daughter the soul who does my will that
is live in divine will whatever she does she does in my will she forces me to do whatever
she does together with her.
So if she receives Communion in my will I repeat the acts that I did in communicating
myself so notice the importance of fusing in receiving the Lord and I renew the complete
fruit of my sacramental life therefore your act of receiving Communion is absolutely
vitally important.
If she prays in my will I pray with her and I renew the fruit of my prayers.
If she suffers if she works if she speaks in my will I suffer with her renewing the fruit
of my pains I work and speak in her and I renew the fruit of my works and words and
so with all the rest it's not wonderful.
So the importance of fusing and letting the Lord repeat his life in us I think that's
absolutely marvelous.
So December the 30th we come to a very important message again but as we go on you'll hear
me saying that each one of them is very important.
How Jesus made us free in our will and in our love no matter how often you fuse no matter
how deep you are in Communion with him you are always free and you see this continuously
in the writings of Louisa and so you comment to those wonderful moments that I call moments
in which they're having a tiff together and then he says to her you're free you know.
You can pull out at this anytime you like that's the exact opposite for people who get into
satanic worship the moment Satan gets a grip on your will he takes it and slaves you and
you are no longer free that's why exorcism is one of the very important ministries of
the church to free people because the people getting into the occult have no idea even
the ones who say they understand it and everything they don't have an idea that from that instant
they're not free and the great gift that God has given to us is free will but no matter
how committed you are to the Lord you are always free always free and therefore he wants
us to make a continuous acts all the time so continue in my usual state Louisa said I
was thinking about the pains of my loveable Jesus offering my interior martyrdom united
to the pains of Jesus now she gets 10 out of 10 instead of complaining that life is
very hard for her and everything she's now united her martyrdom with the martyrdom of
Jesus very important no matter how small the pain you get in any part of your body would
you please connect it with the passion of Jesus gain his infinite merits fuse raise it
up to the divine level and offer it for souls and you're doing an incredible good all the
time it's much better than paracetamal so Jesus said my daughter my executioners were
able to lacerate my body insult me trample upon me but this needs to be underlined in
green white and gold they could not touch either my will or my love they could touch
my body but they couldn't touch the essence of me divine will and love is how you describe
God these I wanted free so that like two currents that might run and run without anyone being
able to hinder them pouring myself out for the good of all and also for my very enemies
now I think it's in Maria Valtorta that Jesus explains it's something that's terribly important
to me Jesus explains that during the scourging that he was completely still inside of himself
that became desperately important for me last January when I had the problem with the eye
because I said I now need to experience it this complete stillness when there's something
awful happening to you on the outside and he gave it to me in so far as someone at my
level could take it and it made an incredible difference I now know what he's actually talking
about this complete stillness you can't touch my will and you can't touch my love you can't
stop me from offering this in divine currency for souls nothing can stop me it's the most
incredible moment of freedom so even though what happened to me was a disaster on a human
level on a divine level was completely different because I would never have got this insight
do you know what I mean and he's saying that no matter what happens to you no matter who
is responsible for it you can still turn it into something incredibly beautiful for God
okay oh how my will and my love triumphed in the midst of my enemies that needs to be
colored as well there's this disaster happening on the outside and inside he has complete triumph
because neither his will nor his love was touched what he wanted to do and what he decided to
do with discouraging held and he decided he was doing it out of love he was not reacting
to the people causing him pain do you see where you stay up at the divine will level you don't
come down to the level of passions now there's nothing like discouraging forget me back into
passions and anger and reaction and resentment and blah blah blah now he couldn't go into
that because he was divine as well as human but there's nothing like pain for really bringing
you down you know and so it's during a time when you're experiencing pain that you can
click into this incredible moment of Jesus and and taste a little bit of his victory they
would strike me with scourges but I would strike their hearts with my love look at that now
you heard me saying flinging the the flames of love into their hearts this is what he's
doing it's amazing and with my will I would chain them they would prick my head with thorns
and my love would turn on the light in their minds to make me known to see you see throwing
the shafts of light into their minds I just want you to hear where this comes from they
would open wounds on me and my love would heal the wounds of their souls so my physical wounds
was healing their spiritual wounds isn't that incredible they gave me death and my love gave
life back to them this is truly divine so much so that as I breathed my last on the cross
the flames of my love you see touching their hearts forced them to prostrate themselves
before me and confess me as true God there's the triumph you throw the flames of divine
love into their hearts and it first of all cancels their their hatred and their rebellion
against God gradually softens them down and sets the fire of love going in them so I want
to give you a Matthew 2754 truly this man was a son of God that's what Jesus is referring
to never was I so glorious and triumphant as I was in my pains now people in the divine
will have got to grasp that reality because this is completely different to much lower
spiritualities that allows you to get healed of absolutely everything and all pains are
got rid of and you are trotting along like anybody else but with the religious coat on
the top of it whereas in the divine will we actually look for identification with Jesus
never was I so glorious and triumphant as I was in my pains during the course of my
mortal life down here now he said in my likeness I made the soul free in her will and her love
you see what he's getting at now he wants the same thing from us at our level so others
might take possession of the external works of the creature but no one no one can do so
with her interior with her will and her love it doesn't matter what people say or do to
you they cannot touch these two if you stay fused in the divine will so for that I want
to give you Romans 8 verses 38 and 39 and it begins with if God is on your side who can
be against you so if you stay fused you stay in there that all obstacles will have to fall
down before you no one no one can do so with our interior with her will and with her love
I myself wanted her to be free in this so that freely not being forced this will and
this love might run towards me and immersing herself in me she might offer me the noblest
and purest acts which the soul can give me which are divine acts and since I am free and
so is she we might pour ourselves into each other in other words we fuse into each other
I fuse in him and he fuses in me and together we run for souls isn't that wonderful we run
towards heaven first of all to love and glorify the father this is the very reason why we have
this divine will mission these are the two motivations we have and these are the two things
we want for Dromantine as well to run towards heaven to glorify the father and to dwell together
with the most holy trinity but also to run towards the art to do good for all souls so
there you have it to give glory to God and to save souls we run into the hearts of all
to strike them with our love and chain them with our will there's your shafts of light
and love and to make conquests of them greater dowry I could not give to the creature but
where where can the creature make greater display of this free will and free love it is in suffering
it's the greatest place where you can do it it is in suffering that love grows the will
is magnified and as queen the soul rules over herself she binds my heart and her pain surround me
like a crown they move me to pity and I let myself be dominated and whether you like it or
whether you don't you get your dose of suffering in some way I cannot resist the pains of a loving
soul Jesus said and I keep her at my side as a queen now in that piece that I've just read I
want to give you Sam 25 verse 4 and Sam 119 verse 168 in the pains the dominion of this soul is so
great that they make her acquire noble dignified pleasing heroic disinterested ways similar to our
ways I'm just giving you English there is that okay and the other souls compete to let themselves
be dominated by this soul the way we would say that in ordinary English is that when we know
somebody is ahead of us we don't mind listening to that person at all in fact we get again inspiration
from somebody who is ahead of us and the more the soul operates with me is united with me identifies
herself with me the more I feel absorbed in the soul this is the possession of God and this is the
ultimate experience on this earth when we come to take possession of God in our souls then we
have reached heaven on earth that okay so as she thinks I feel my thought being absorbed in her
mind as she looks as she speaks as she breeds I feel my gaze my voice my breath my action my step
and heartbeat being absorbed in hers she absorbs all of me that this is called the possession of God
and while she absorbs me she keeps acquiring my ways and my likeness I keep gazing at myself in
her continuously and I find myself so I want to give you two Corinthians 3 18 we become like that
which we worship and I want to give you Galatians 220 again because he says I find myself so I no
longer live Christ lives in me so that's a very beautiful piece that simply requires you to sit
with it and to deal with it prayerfully okay because we we've done it very short we'll do it very
short when they will take a break January the 10th 1917 how sanctity is formed from little things
Jesus told me my daughter sanctity is formed from little things so one who despises the little
things cannot be holy anybody can move up and to the big event it would be like someone who despises
the little grains of wheat which as many of them are united together form the mass of wheat and by
it an electing to unite them they would cause the necessary and daily nourishment of the human
being to be lacking in other words the wheat makes bread in the same way one who neglected to unite
many little acts together would cause the nourishment of sanctity to be lacking and just as one cannot
live without food in the same way without the food of the little acts the true shape of sanctity
the mass sufficient to form real sanctity would be lacking I'm going to stop there for a few minutes